la coutume c'est que ceux qui sont là
pour la première fois hein tout le monde
va se lever vous embrasser à ranouré
hier soir il faisait bon rire au Théâtre
André Merot chaque année au mois de mars
le théâtre ouvre sa scène à neuf
artistes pour trois grandes soirées
d'humour dans le cadre du festival de
roncours le plus important dans un
festival c'est d'essayer de travailler
la différence comme ça le public passe
une belle soirée en rencontrant des des
des des univers différentes parce que
l'humour n'est pas ce qu'on voit que à
la télé aujourd'hui c'est un peu
formater des fois et il a un envie de de
surprendre on peut pas dire que ça monte
mercredi après jeudi encore mieux
vendredi encore mieux non c'est juste
chaque soirée a sa couleur c'est ça ce
mercredi 20 mars Patrice Laffond
président du jury lance officiellement
l'ouverture du festival alors j'annonce
officiellement le 17e festival de rock
en cours
ouvert l'objectif de ce rendez-vous
d'humour incontournable dans les
Yvelines depuis maintenant 17 ans
révéler au public de jeunes talents et
les aider à se produire mais j'aime bien
en France quand même parler de ma
famille royale comme ça vous les
imaginez puisqu'on va bientôt vous
annexer ça n'inquiète jamais personne le
public est de plus en plus curieux
aussi j'ai pas été moi aux émissions de
ruier mais je dois leur reconnaître ça
c'est que ils ont amené les gens aussi
dans les salles de gens qui n'y sont pas
parce que les gens se sont dit mais
tiens il y a beaucoup de gens qui sont
marrants et qu'on connait pas alors
allons dans les cafés théâtres allons
dans les festival d'humour durant ces TR
jours de compétition trois humoristes
par soir se produisent face à un public
qui vote pour son coup de cœur devant un
jury de professionnels qui récompense
les plus
prometteurs je meurs avant la mamie en
plus c'est la MAM qui vient habiter chez
moi
évidemment le plus sympa c'est quand
même le public même si ce qui est
chouette c'est de cumuler les deux
maintenant les JIS parfois font font des
erreurs le public je pense moins mais
pourquoi parce que le jury parfois voit
des choses plus loin c'est-à-dire que il
sent que tel artiste
sera dans les codes de demain ils
peuvent se tromper totalement mais ils
peuvent avoir la la bonne réponse le
public il est dans les codes
d'aujourd'hui si vous le faites marrer
il va voter pour vous on vous souhaite
bonne chance alors on dit jamais bonne
chance je rtire on dit merde je crois
MERCI on dit pas
merci quelques sketch plus tard Alex
visorec a conquis les spectateurs et a
remporté ce soir-là le prix du public
finalement c'était un un merci qui vous
apporté chance mais je remercie TV fil
78 78 come on dirait chez moi vous avvez
choisi le bon cheval je suis ravi je
avais dit je pensais qu'effectivement le
public d'ici allait adhérer à à je je
dirais un humour référencé en fait et et
je suis super content parce que ça a
fonctionné
et et puis voilà il y avait il y avait
une chouette ambiance et pour pour un
mercredi soir pour l'ouverture il reste
encore de jours de festival pour
découvrir les futurs talents du rire
ceux qui peut-être prendront la relève
de Julie Ferrier Éric Antoine Olivier de
Benoît ou encore Arnaud samère repéré
eux aussi à
rquencour les artistes se produiront
pour une grande soirée de gala au
théâtre montanci à Versailles le jeudi
avril de sous la
neig super de la
neige